pack your bags for San Francisco the
flights must be super cheap because it's
a complete Wasteland that's right
episode 5 of Monarch Legacy of monsters
takes us to ruin San Fran roughly a year
after gday the day Godzilla nearly wiped
out the entire city fighting off two
Titans in this video we'll be talking
about that mysterious map Ma's betrayal
Lee Shaw and captivity Kate's past and a
whole lot more so like And subscribe
it's time to get into it the big
breakthrough in this episode revolves
hero Shir randa's map one that is found
in his office in Tokyo and the other in
San Francisco by lining up these
locations from Bill randa's files which
were conveniently stored to A Cloud by
May the group finds out two of these
locations were San Francisco where
Godzilla attacked and Alaska where they
encountered the frostar it can be
assumed that Hiroshi was investigating
these locations and since canaro
theorized his father made it out of
Alaska he's probably on the next spot on
the map which Kate says is in Africa now
if you look up these coordinates you'll
find they point to Algeria in Northern
Africa so it's possible that's where
we're headed next at the beginning of
episode 5 our characters find themselves
imprisoned by Monarch at their Command
Post in Alaska while Duval goes through
May's things she notices multiple
passports one which has the name Lyra
Mato of Tacoma Washington last episode
we saw may receive a phone call from
ayra who she referred to as her sister
but why then would she have her sister
's passport may also has a different
last name although that could be because
her sister's married or their half
sisters if they're even sisters at all
there's definitely something about her
past that may is hiding like I don't
trust anyone who's willing to throw a
phone in the water after a call at the
end of the episode May calls Duval who's
offered her a way out of her situation a
way out is also the title of this
episode remember that may has expressed
she wants her business and life back so
teaming up with Monarch may be her way
out of it my guess is that may will keep
Monarch informed on what the randers are
doing and where they're going unlike the
others Colonel Lee Shaw is held at
Monarch being deemed too much of a
threat but over the course of his
interrogation we get a few interesting
pieces of information first check out
the way he looks at Ko in that film reel
from the Philippines it's been an
ongoing theory that Lee is hiroshi's
actual father making him Ken and Kate's
grandfather Duval also notes how good
Lee looks for his age back in 1952 he
would have been in his mid-30s it's
currently 2015 which should make Lee
somewhere in his '90s and he definitely
doesn't look 90 Verdugo briefly mentions
a mission that Lee went on that went bad
if you stick around for my trailer
sleuthing section I think I know which
Mission she's referring to something
must have happened then that has slowed
Lee's aging but more on that in the
sleuthing section Verdugo also mentions
she didn't like what Monarch did to him
after all he sacrificed so expect this
to be highlighted in the upcoming
episodes as we delve deeper into the
1950s timeline Lee also hates Monarch's
current Let Them Fight strategy a
reference to the line by Monarch
biologist Dr ishiro Cawa Let Them Fight
I think Lee joined Monarch believing
they were doing something good and as
Monarch's policy changed so did his
resistance to it the main focus of this
episode however is Kate's past not only
do we meet her mother who sent Kate to
Japan with this secret intention of
finding out if Heros she was cheating on
her but we also get these flashbacks
leading up to gday Kate's Mother
Caroline works for the urban recovery
program a government organization task
with bringing items from the fenced off
San Francisco disaster Zone back to
their rightful owners this comes in
useful since Kate and the Gang hop to
find new clues in hoshi's San Francisco
office just like there were clues in his
office in Tokyo the roote her journey
she experiences several flashbacks
involving a lover named Dany from my
understanding it looks as though Kate
was still seeing a toxic ex while
simultaneously stringing Dany along a
partner who actually cared about her so
much so that Dany asked Kate to move in
with her Kate like her father has a
history of running away when evacuating
with the school she ultimately decides
not to go with Dany Kate's Journey
Through the subway tunnel is also a
metaphor for her journey facing her past
it's only when we face it head on that
we can come out the other side stronger
perhaps this is why mace is the famous
Robert cross line the only way out is
through two random things I wanted to
mention were the kids watching the
attack footage in Hawaii seen in 2014's
Godzilla just a day before gday and the
name of the coffee shop grounds hero Now
we move on to our trailer sleuthing
section where we go over the season's
trailers to see what we can expect in
the upcoming weeks keep in mind I won't
go over every shot just the ones where
something new has been learned we have
yet to see this shot of Hiroshi Randa
and whether or not it's a flashback with
the team finding that one of the
locations of his map points to Africa
this might be where all these desert
shot come in notice the weird scientific
device behind him and the mountain
difference between trailer 1 and two
suggesting Godzilla is somewhere behind
him blending into the mountains with
Verdugo talking to Lee about a mission
he did that went wrong I think this has
got to be it we'll see this team
entering a monarch sphere an identical
yet much older one can be seen in the
background of this shot my guess is this
was a mission to the hollow Earth
essentially the world within earth that
are home to the Titans we saw in
Godzilla versus Kong whether it be
exposure to radiation or time working
differently there something happened to
prolong Lee's life and I think it
happened on this Mission we'll also see
this shot of Lee in front of a computer
that says primed leading me to believe
he'll let off some sort of explosive it
also looks like Tim is not done with Ken
and Kate they're in some sort of airport
Tim has always wanted to keep things
secret from Verdugo so he may actually
end up helping them even if if it means
going against Monarch he'll eventually
have Kate Ken and may accompany him to
the Monarch offices in Virginia they
also end up in the desert with Lee and
Duval where Godzilla emerges so it looks
like all of them are converging here for
Godzilla's return we'll see Kate holding
her dad's map so maybe this is Africa
like they had mentioned in hiroshi's
office in the behind the scenes footage
we see this weird looking sphere which
looks an awfully lot like the photo
found on hiroshi's desk in San Francisco
so if one things for certain the next
few episodes we'll see God Zilla and a
whole bunch of balls now I turn it over
to you I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much